Хто замовив вбивство Каті Гандзюк?
Після смерті херсонської активістки десятки громадських, правозахисних організацій
по всій країні активізували кампанію з вимогою знайти і покарати замовника нападу на активістку.
У зверненні на захист громадянського суспільства вони вимагають відправити у відставку
не лише керівництво херсонської поліції, а йкерівництво ГПУ і МВС,
які за майже 96 днів розслідування після нападу,
поки Катерина була жива,так і не назвали ім’я замовника.
Перші речі, які треба зробити - це звільнення Луценка і Авакова.
Тому що ці люди безпосередньо відповідальні за провал правоохоронної реформи.
Вимога правоохоронної реформи - це вимога Євромайдану.
Вона не виконана, провалена, вона абсолютно знівельована, як ідея.
Треба звільнити цих осіб, щоб вони понесли публічну відповідальність.
І бажано,щоб вони понесли відповідальність перед законом.
Віталій Устименко відомий в Одесі своєю жорсткою критикою на адресу мера Труханова
та його бізнес-партнерів.
На нього самого кілька разів скоювали замахи.
Останнього разу – влітку,з ножем. Усі ці випадки не розслідувані.
Нерозслідувані до кінця й інші напади - загалом на понад 50 активістів за останні два роки.
Сергій Стерненко, який, зокрема, теж боровся проти одеських чиновників-корупціонерів,
пережив три напади.
Він вважає,що через 4 роки після Євромайдану громадські активісти
знаходяться в такій же небезпеці, як і за часів екс-президента Януковича.
Поліція не просто не розслідуєрезонансі злочини,
а, фактично, покриває замовників, організаторів, виконавців.
Вона стаєпричетною до цих злочинів, і є досить серйозні підставивважати,
що до низки резонанснихзлочинів співробітники поліції
могли бути також причетні як співорганізатори.
Активістів жорстоко б’ють, трощать їхнє майно, обливають кислотою, як Катю Гандзюк.
Вбивають. Просто посеред білого дня.
Лише від початку цього року в Україні було скоєно три резонансні вбивства активістів.
Чим далі від Києва, тим більш відчутна бездіяльність правоохоронних органів,
вважає член Харківського антикорупційного центру ДмитроБулах.
Його громадська організація займається, зокрема, боротьбою з розкраданням землі у місті.
На мене були напади, на мого колегу були напади. Вбивство, на жаль, було в області.
Ситуація в районах областівзагалі критична, тому що там, фактично, феодалізм.
Родини правлять, займають структуру виконавчу, судову, правоохоронну сфери.
І там дуже важко працювати звичайним людям,
які просто небайдужі до ситуації в країні абоу своєму місті.
Смерть Катерини Гандзюк шокувала її колег з громадського сектора.
Але ні Дмитро, ні інші активісти, які приїхали попрощатися з Гандзюк, зупинятися не збираються.
Кажуть, у небезпеці не лише громадські діячі , а й пересічні громадяни,
яким держава наразі не може гарантувати елементарного захисту,
а також покарання за злочини.
Тому активісти проводять своє незалежне розслідування щодо замовників вбивства Гандзюк.